I'm walking with a friend of mine quite
regularly and he's a tough guy he's
worked with delinquents his whole life
he's like a social worker superhero the
other day this guy walked by us on the
street and he was pretty run down he was
probably in his mid-40s and he stopped
and he looked at me and he came over and
he said I love you and I walked away and
my friend said you sure have a lot of
men coming up to you and saying that
they love you you know my wife too she
said she's seen a whole different side
of men especially since we started
touring because of generally when people
approached me they're very polite she
said that's showed her a whole side of
men that she didn't even know existed
there isn't anything that's more
rewarding than trying to do things right
all other forms of reward pale why
comparison and there's nothing that's
more adventurous than telling the truth
and so if you're looking for an
adventure boy that's an adventure